les transporteurs ne sont pas restés
inactifs dans leur camion aujourd'hui
ils ont eu plusieurs réunions comme ce
matin à la ccm et en ce moment nous
sommes à contacter entreprises où se
déroule en ce moment une réunion pour
nous en parler
monsieur trompette un des porte parole
de ce mouvement me sont complètes
qu'est ce qui se passe exactement ce
moment à trois portables d'entreprise
mais là en ce moment on est en train de
discuter un petit peu sur le conflit
donc ce qui se passe et ce qu'on
souhaite faire
donc demain en faire dans l'avenir
quelles sont les pistes qui se dégage à
peu près ben pour le moment donc on a vu
de la cci le président de la ccm ce
matin donc a priori
ils sont prêts aussi à nos idées donc à
travailler avec si bien sûr le président
marie jeanne ne veut travailler avec les
techniciens de la cctm alors quel sens
la tournure de votre mouvement vous
allez dormir sur place ce soir vous avez
camper sur place où vous allez prendre
une autre option ben donc nous allons
dormir sur place ça c'est sûr et puis à
partir de demain bon mais il faut
s'attendre quand même à ce que ça dit
aussi c'est un petit peu on va monter
d'un cran
si vous souhaitez vraiment c'est discuté
avec alfred marie jeanne président de la
collectivité de martinique
si vous les différents points de votre
plateforme mais absolument comme donc
quand on a commencé donc
nous on pensait pas arriver jusque là de
toute façon on a tout fait pour essayer
de négocier
on a frappé à toutes les portes
maintenant
un dernier billet on n'a pas eu de
réponses on n'a rien eu donc on était
obligé de de faire ce mouvement là merci
monsieur trompette
voilà donc le point ici à contacter
l'entreprise